okay hey guys my name is Mark one of the
cofounders of Piper and two days ago
Andy and and Dennis they actually asked
me to come speak at this colloquium and
before committing to and I looked on the
website and I saw that it was actually
an EE colloquium and I I majored in
molecular biology and then I looked at
the speakers on the website and all the
speakers had PhDs or Turing awards or
both and my only connection with the PhD
was I dropped out of mine a few years
back so so I had a some hesitation
whenever I was you know deciding whether
to give this talk or not and and Andy
said you know I think you have something
that you could tell this group about
which is how to create a product and
something that kids love today which is
what you made and and how to create a
product that not only is interesting for
kids but also actually has a social
mission of letting kids become engineers
and getting them to be engineers so I'm
gonna talk to you about that about how
we made Piper what it is how it gets
kids engaged engineering and a huge part
of that is actually my own story how I
got started with this and what motivated
me so I'm gonna start with that I was
was born in in Ukraine actually that's
me with my grandparents and I was a few
years old
and I look pretty good back then and
what the thing about Ukraine in the
1990s was that the infrastructure was
falling apart the Soviet Union had just
collapsed and nothing worked I remember
you know the the sewage the toilets
wouldn't work the electricity would
start working we wouldn't have heating
for days and there weren't any products
in the stores so what you had to do to
survive was you actually had to fix and
build things yourself I remember me and
my grandpa would go on I had a toy gun
and something broke we took it apart he
started it back together for me I
remember one time during the winter
months they turned off all electricity
and we had candles for a while but in
the candles ran out so I started
thinking you know why don't we use
Christmas lights so my grandpa said why
not we we got some 9-volt batteries
wired them up the Christmas lights and
it worked and we had light and those
early experiences in Ukraine kind of
tinkering and building stuff that
actually was applicable that helped us
survive day to day really really shaped
my thinking going forward
I learned that environment you're in it
it's malleable whatever ever you're
placed no matter what the circumstances
are you can change it you can alter
where you are and what happens to you
and the other thing I learned is that
you don't have to be an expert you know
my grandpa he was retired but he had
before he had previously been an army
officer in the Soviet Army so so he had
no experiences he just learned from
scratch because there was a necessity
and the final thing that I learned was
that even as a child learning those
lessons helped shape my mindset going
forward I saw everything as something
that I could change something that I
could tweak out always ask questions you
know why is this chair structured this
way or why why is that system design in
that certain way can we change it can we
build it in a different way and so when
I was nine years old my mother she she
got a scholarship to come study in the
United States so she brought me to the
United States and that's me when I was
nine with my mom and I was completely
blown away when I came here the
opportunities the resources here I I
realized wow a friend of a friend was we
we Louisiana and he did he got catfished
he had a boat so he just said you want
to come out on the boat one one weekend
so with that that's where the pictures
from and I remember thinking like only
like oligarchs had boats in Ukraine and
here's an ordinary guy had this boat
right so it was a complete mind change
and complete shift in my perspective and
as I moved forward and I learned about
the United States and about the culture
I I saw all these opportunities that
were presented to me as tools as tools
to be able to do something to change
something to make something with and
comparing with my friends in Ukraine I
realized wow I'm getting all these
opportunities that to do something with
them I felt like I'm given a lot of
stuff I need to I need to change
something I need to add I have a net add
to the system do something positive so I
went on and I started thinking my mom
showed me to be a doctor you know
immigrant parents they want their kids
to be doctors lawyers I didn't really
see I thought you know medicine was
interesting but I wanted a more
fundamental impact I started
thinking about the human body that's
something we all share and I thought
what if we could make tweaks the human
body what if I could somehow understand
that and design something tweak the
human body so I became AI molecular
biologist and lets me in the lab I went
to Princeton and I did a lot of biology
research at Princeton but as I got
deeper and deeper into research and made
have made some discoveries and
neuroscience and genetics I realized
that all the discoveries I was making
they actually they didn't really impact
people they were all done on cells on
nematodes on flies they didn't actually
impact individuals that's what I really
wanted to do I wanted to create things
that that had an impact to people I
changed people's lives that overall make
people's lives better and so I thought
okay a my junior year I there were there
were these scholarships to go conduct
some kind of project and global health
and I wasn't I wasn't studying global
health but I somehow convinced Princeton
to give me this money to go to Africa
and I thought I I could there's lots of
diseases that are very easily curable
unsolvable in places like Africa like
malaria diarrheal disease things like
that and if I could only bring my
knowledge the things that I know to the
folks there especially to kids because
they're they're the ones who are most
vulnerable and they're the ones who have
the longest lives to live but if I could
somehow bring that knowledge these kids
maybe I could impact their lives in some
positive way so that's mean in Ghana I
was in the schoolhouse I don't know if
you notice it kind of looks like a
prison as well for those bars and I I
designed this thing where I actually was
an experimental setup we had four
classrooms two of them we were teaching
about health through games
two of them were teaching about health
the standard you know just write it on
the board memorize it come back and take
a test and we were doing all this all
these like really great activities we
were testing the kids baseline
experiments that and and you know I'll
never forget like then of one of the one
of the days the students were coming out
we were given the candy as you know as a
reward for participating and one of the
students said thank you and he said like
you know are we gonna are we gonna kind
of learn are we gonna do anything else
besides kind of learn this information
and I was like well no kind of the idea
is to teach you guys about how to
prevent malaria what causes malaria what
malaria even is
you know how you should wash your hands
why like bacteria they're microscopic
things like that and she said you know
we actually already know all these
things and I thought to myself wait come
again what did you say and she's like
yeah we we just really like you know
interacting with you and like we think
it's a great new experience for us to do
all these things with you and it's a new
teaching style but I mean we know
fundamentally why does by disease happen
it's not the knowledge that's lacking
here it's more like the infrastructure
you know it's really hot and it's too
hot for us to sleep under mosquito nets
for example or like the washing wall was
like a mile away it's actually
impractical for us to wash our hands all
the time it was these infrastructural
problems that that were actually
standing in the way it wasn't a
knowledge gap and and that really that
really stuck with me I realized wow you
know it's it's actually about it's
really you know thinking back to my days
in Ukraine and then later in America
it's actually exactly the tools it's
actually giving people the tools like
people have the knowledge but if you
just give them the tools and empower
them a little bit people can create
great things and it's funny I actually
got really sick myself right I was
teaching kids how not to get sick and I
got really sick myself and I remember
the funny thing is they they actually
couldn't diagnose it they thought it was
they thought it was malaria I think it
turned out to be a virus of some sort
but it had very similar syndromes to
malaria and when I got the worst the
worst point I was on the I was on the
call with some doctors here in the
United States and they were asked me in
symptoms and I was telling the seven and
they said oh it could be cerebral
malaria which is kind of the worst the
worst kind of malaria yet they were
saying you could actually go into a coma
in the next 48 hours we need to evacuate
you and I I conveyed this to my hosts
and they we were in a village which was
an hour drive from the next big village
which was another two hours drive from
the actual city that had actually more
like a six hour drive but I actually had
the airport and I said they actually
they're sending a plane to that big city
they're gonna evacuate me we need to
drive there and they were like how do we
how do we drive there you know we have
we have a van that comes once a week to
deliver supplies how are we gonna drive
there so
that kind of put me in a conundrum and I
lay there that night thinking to myself
wow I can really die here I can really
die in this village and looking back on
my life I started thinking you know what
is the impact that I want to have I felt
like it wasn't going to be with just
studying and doing research and doing
biology I felt like it was gonna be with
creating tools to empower individuals
creating something that would give other
people a way to bring themselves up to
empower themselves luckily there was
there was a taxi actually passing by and
they asked they could they asked his
taxi guided to take me to the next
village which doesn't had a car took me
to the airport and I pull out they they
pulled me out to de France and I was it
was it was close
I did I did thankfully survived and and
I completely changed my focus when I got
when I got back to the states I I looked
around and I thought how can I you know
there's I have I have a desire have a
passion to create tools what's the best
way I can do this and I saw that people
were doing this using technology they
you know right now you can create
something on your computer and I can
scale to millions of people all over the
world and I thought why am i doing
research in a lab pipetting all day long
and maybe they'll come welcome and maybe
a great discovery maybe but when I could
actually be creating tools that could
impact millions of people and in some
way give them a way to move forward
themselves so I started teaching myself
computer science and electronics and
kind of spent last year of Princeton and
then the whole summer after that doing
that and right around that time you guys
might have heard of this the Raspberry
Pi had had come out and I was really
fascinated by this device it was you
know it's a Linux board it cost $35 and
no one really knew what it could do but
you know enthusiasts were buying it up
like hotcakes
because I think it went back you know it
brought back memories of the old
computers of things like the Apple to
that you you actually had to build and
program yourself and so lots of lots of
older folks were buying these computers
buying these raspberry PI's and not only
knowing what to do with them there were
some interesting projects and I started
thinking what if you know this
is really $35 not that expensive what if
this could be a platform to give kids a
way to get into technology whether it's
whether it's coding or building the
actual computer building electronics on
top of it what if we could do something
like that
with this platform so that's I got this
I got this fellowship to to start the
PhD I went to Oxford changed my focus
from biology to image processing was
doing image processing of cancers
actually and on the side I was building
the first prototypes of what I thought
would be a mini computer based on the
Raspberry Pi that I wanted to use I
wanted to use to teach kids about
technology I thought if we can empower
kids at a young age to be comfortable
and to use technology you know not not
to just look at these kind of black box
devices that we all have as black boxes
that work on magic but as something that
they could tinker and take apart and
then maybe even remix and add onto then
I think we'll be moving forward and I
felt like I personally be moving forward
my my desire to empower individuals so
the the first is this video so the first
the first sort of yeah iteration of this
was was it was a black box that came
with this keyboard the Raspberry Pi
battery pack and you put it together
yourself kind of like you see here it
was pretty rough around the edges as you
can see we're using foam we had to like
duct tape the screen to the that to the
box but but the idea got across you know
we had an instruction manual that showed
how you put this together and once you
hooked it all up you you actually
started to learn how to do some basic
coding and I wouldn't recommend you go
through airport security with this but
the the interface was was very much you
know we started with the most basic
thing we started with HTML and CSS
I'm sorry teaching kids how to make
their own websites well something that
that was basic that could also though
they could also see implemented right
that was the idea you'd make a website
and then we could easily publish it for
you and then millions of people can have
access to it theoretically so and here
and we did a kind of a story like manner
where this is another part of the part
of the part of the experience you'd play
through and so we we we we ship these
boxes to first just to some classrooms
in India we had several schools this
school and then the other school to
start start playing with with these
boxes that we started calling Piper's
and the reason we came up with a name
Piper was we thought of the buildings
that surround us as you know they're
full of pipes that bring in water
electricity and they're very integral to
build it to us living and using these
building but we don't know how those
pipes actually a piping system works and
the same thing applies for the Internet
that's very integral to our existence
day to day but a lot of us most of us
especially kids they don't know how the
internet works so through Piper you
actually became you became Piper you
became the person understanding the
architecture so you can then implement
your own ways of playing with it and
I'll show you a demo of one of the first
things that we started with it was it
was this here I think you can see it and
this is what came on these on these on
these computers you know it's very basic
you type in your name and then you'd go
to the first lesson and this was
specifically for that for the schools in
India so you kind of go through and this
girl Garrity she would guide you through
making a simple biography and you'll be
doing this by making a website and it
would look like this at the end let me
actually delete that as you guys you
know how to use this you click left
right to move forward and there's an
editor there's a preview screen and this
is this is similar to some of the other
tools out there we looked at what was
know what people were using to teach
basic website making and we we copied
some of those elements and some of the
lingo here some of the some of this
history and background and then right
away actually after you've gone through
the beginnings you actually start doing
this yourself
you type in hello innate and h1 tags now
let's get to the checkpoint so and then
there is a checkpoint somewhere there it
is there's a checkpoint so you type this
in and you type your name or you can say
hello and it would yeah you'd go to the
next next part and you learn more about
the headings and you try other headings
you could cheat and you could copy and
paste but that wasn't recommended and
this is this is what we started with
this was the first sort of iteration we
made this and as you went through you
you basically filled out this web page
on the on the right you started with
headers and you filled in some
information and then as you moved as you
move forward you would well I guess I
can yeah I can keep it here you you
would add images you would add CSS you
would add some some boxes where people
could enter in their name and get in
touch with you and what we learned very
very quickly from from downloading these
two kids was that kids weren't actually
that interested in the software I mean
you guys were looking at and there's a
lot of clicks there's a lot of
information we were trying to like get
them excited we're like look you can
make a website and you can put it online
and people can see it and they were like
yeah like okay I mean maybe that's
interesting but they were really
interested by that by the physical stuff
they hadn't seen that before they liked
the physical building and they liked
assembly the computer they could the
screen lighting up so we thought okay
you know let's keep this physical stuff
and we did more demos back in America as
well and kids kept talking to us about
this game called minecraft
yes can be playing Minecraft on these
computers and we don't know if minecraft
was so and for those of you who are not
parents so minecraft is a digital Legos
it's a virtual building blocks game that
actually gives you the freedom to do
whatever you want this is I think a
plane from lost that somebody rebuilt in
Minecraft so then what I'm showing you
is is the creative side of my car you
can use these digital building blocks to
create anything you want can build plane
from lost you can build these large huge
structures and I'll show you in a second
how this whole game dynamic works but
you can build something like this and
then what people do is they expand on
this right if i zoom out of this you
actually see people build huge
structures in the virtual world and this
is this is the full map of what I was
just showing you and this this takes
this takes years people spent years of
their lives building these virtual
structures and so we thought wow this is
amazing
kids love this and I think they love it
you know we thought okay they loved it
they loved the building breaking aspects
they liked playing with with their
friends on servers how can we make what
we're doing a little more like like
minecraft you know so we thought okay
okay we're gonna stick with this whole
internet web page element because that's
important that's a way tax is the world
so why don't we let kids create web
pages but also break with web pages in
the same way that minecraft lets you do
it so no oops let's see where's the code
so you know I go to Wikipedia and I
heard something about not doing live
demos oh well and how it always fails
you can see it on if you can see this is
that you guys see that there's a little
guy I just I just did that pasted some
code on the console and was a little guy
who just landed in the Wikipedia page
and we thought why don't we let kids
explore webpage is the same way they
explore worlds and minecraft so with the
spacebar you can actually break
characters you can break you can break
the text you can destroy whatever text
you want you can explore this web page
and for something like say you have this
image say you want to like get this
image into your inventory so you want to
possess the image and then go and put it
back somewhere else you can hit it and
then underneath is an image tag that if
I type up here I can actually mine the
tag and then it goes into my inventory
so we tried to structure mining webpages
in the same way that minecraft
structures their gameplay through mining
through acquiring elements and then
through placing them further so and then
there's also a feature where you know
you can put your your own photo on a
Wikipedia page and again kids kids were
like yeah this is interesting but can we
you know can we play can we play some
minecraft on these computers and we're
like but this is sort of like Minecraft
and they said no no this is this isn't
that interesting this is boring so then
we said okay let us actually let us
actually ourselves play Minecraft really
understand what is it about this game
that kids are so addicted to and for
those of you who I've never seen
minecraft I'm gonna just quickly show
you what it looks like and what the
gameplay quickly looks like because it's
very interesting it's not it's actually
it's more than a game it's very much
like a like like a whole small universe
the basic point there's two different
birds there's a creative mode which I
was showing you you can build whatever
you want there's also a survival mode
and the survival mode is kind of in a
way like real life you're dropped as
this as this character onto onto this
planet and great new world your goal
there is no goal that's the thing you're
just there and it's kind of like life in
that way right
mmm-hmm you appear you stick around for
a while and then you die and the same
thing here and at night you know you can
just basically stand around do nothing
at night these are these monsters come
out and they they try to kill you and so
you can you can you can avoid the
monsters by big
yourself into a ditch and not doing
anything or you can do something a lot
more interesting you can build yourself
a house if you build yourself traps to
trap these monsters you can kind of go
out and explore and there's so many
possibilities of what you can do that it
keeps you engaged for very long periods
of time here I am you know gonna play a
little bit of Minecraft to show you what
it's like I'm like this character this
is all dirt around me and the thing
about Minecraft is I can mine every
single piece I can I can mine the dirt
and I can mine I combine these trees and
they all after when I do that they all
go into my inventory and then eventually
as I'm doing this I can then build
structures like these houses I can build
castles sometimes there are you know
good guys like these so I can interact
with and if I interact with them I can
trade resources with them and it's so
what happened when we started playing
Minecraft ourselves is we actually
couldn't stop we I think at one point we
we started playing and then we played
for like a good 12 hours straight until
we realized wow this is really addicting
and we understand why kids like it for
kids it's a way to create whatever they
want it's complete freedom completely
complete empowerment and on top of that
it's you know it's kind of like Lego but
they can do it with their friends you
can set up a server and the two of you
or the three of you can go and build
huge structures build ships build
castles build whatever you want together
right it's it's actually the the most
it's brilliant because you know you you
know when you were I mean I'm sure a lot
of you when you were younger you would
build tree houses you would build
construction sets with your friends but
that was all like very very like in one
place it was only for a short amount of
time when you got a playdate here you
could keep going it was always it was
you could play however long you wanted
to it was always there and we thought
how do we how do we leverage you know
this minecraft this game to get kids
into into technology building yeah you
see your face what you see is what you
get interface there is possible right
generally it's a good question so for
most players it's what you see is what
you get you have a point and click and
the movement a lot of people what they
do is they they do write mods so mods
and modifications they allow you to
programmatically change the environment
to give yourself either more power-ups
yourself better armor better weapons
great structures around you interface
with other players you can do basically
anything you want has it potentially
dire that the success of this paradigm
might be grounded in its relationship to
the leg of experience as a formative
process that happened hands on and that
the attractor here is basically
leveraging off the mindset which which
Lego already had fostered in the far
mobile busway than the computer
interface would ever be able to achieve
in other words playing with Lego blocks
is is way more of an interactive
experience than I mean that's a very
interesting question and we've thought
about that a lot you know does does the
Lego actually help kids get into
Minecraft there's a whole you know and
the them building physically give them
the mindset of like there's blocks I can
create I can build things that are much
bigger than just blocks themselves and
that's possibly that's possibly yeah
that's possibly true some of things you
get in Minecraft is this whole crap the
reason is called Minecraft as you craft
things so combinations of blocks
actually give you power-ups armor
different elements the ability to do
more than just point and click and break
blocks so you have this kind of although
all this potential that you kind of sort
of unlock as you move through the game
that Lego doesn't actually give you you
know with Lego you built something and
then you can create a storyline around
it in your mind but you can't unlock
hidden powers
sure my source you can do that there so
obviously can do something sorry you
can't do with Legos you're saying thank
you with Legos you can build things and
interact with the real world
yeah sure I mean you can I guess what
I'm saying is if we're using just the
bricks the Lego bricks paradigm
minecraft kind of takes it to a whole
new level and it lets you I mean I mean
the same thing with Mindstorms I think
you're once you written the program and
once you have the capabilities that the
robot has that's pretty limited and what
what you can do with it with other ones
with my storms with my source I see I
mean I guess I guess the point that I
was making was you're you're still
limited to the physical pieces that you
have with both Legos both Mindstorms
yeah sure you can network maybe you can
network I actually don't know if you can
make in your network Joe can you network
- no you can't no actually Lego
Mindstorms is a MIT generated it hasn't
been or was when it first came out the
first engineer here and you could add
models to it which did all sorts of
interesting things including network but
the normal Mindstorms this family thing
is pretty much in this for simple robot
I vote that you continue with your talk
so we thought how do we leverage kids
interest in this game that's so popular
it has 100 million players all over the
world right now how do we leverage that
and get them into engine technology
building you know obviously this whole
pushing them into HTML making websites
wasn't working they like physical
building so we thought how do we combine
these two together the physical building
with
with the Minecraft let me just close
this and this is you know this is kind
of the first version of what we came up
with again you have to assemble your own
computer by assemble you just plug in
the Raspberry Pi into the screen the
battery pack and it launches into
Minecraft but one of the things you have
to do is actually physically build your
own controller so now I gave the
character so you you have a breadboard
you put some buttons on there and you
actually can play the game unless you've
assembled the controller so we thought
yeah that'll get kids you know learning
about electronics and it did to some
degree and you can see here it's
actually a virtual representation on the
right of the part of the Raspberry Pi
and this is a breadboard you can see
their wires are connecting the PI to the
breadboard so he's actually physically
doing the connections like he sees him
in the game and so we were actually
leveraging the the open-endedness of
minecraft to show to use an instruction
manual to show how to build electronics
and you can see the electron flowing
through the wires and then he goes to
the next level once he built this build
back correctly and then the other thing
I think he shows here is he actually
adds a light with a button so it makes a
little flashlight and it shows him how
to do that and I think so he built it
correctly white lights up and we tested
this with kids and what we realized was
you know kids were like yeah this is
cool but then like we still we don't get
to actually play Minecraft there's
actually no there's no like you're using
the Minecraft as like an instruction
manual like that's fine with like
where's the words the zombies where's
the adventure mode how do we actually
get into get into the game we want to
play and like kids would like they would
come over because we said minecraft and
then they would played a little bit and
say okay like actually I'm gonna go back
to doing what I was doing before because
this isn't this isn't that interesting
in itself so we thought okay how do we
you know we kept thinking what if what
if we could somehow and we saw that kids
you know they already were interested in
getting power-ups
and setting up their own servers with
certain mods and we thought why don't we
why don't we actually just let them have
power-ups in this game why don't we make
this game the ultimate minecraft
experience where you could break
hundreds of blocks with one click or you
can generate Auto bridges where you
could find diamonds one of the things
you're trying to find always and dot and
the game is diamonds because you can
actually make armor out of diamonds it's
one of the strongest elements there so
why don't we give them why don't we make
them have proximity sensor that helps
them find diamonds and we decided to try
that out there will be a storyline and
the storyline would lead you through
what you're supposed to do and so this
is this is the sort of the current the
current version what we have oops where
you you first assemble the box and you
assemble the computer and it's it's
color-coded for kids to make it easier
and there's a storyline there's a robot
that goes over to a different planet and
he's faced with challenges here the
challenge is crossing the lava so again
you have like part of the level is
showing you how to build physically once
you've built physically you see the
current flowing you see that you've
built that switch correctly and that
switch actually unlocks the powerup in
the game which is making you this bridge
and so another thing is like I was
telling you finding diamonds you build a
row of LED lights and the closer you get
to the diamond the more lights light up
so it's a proximity sensor finding
diamonds so we married we married this
idea of the gameplay in the storyline
aspect of Minecraft with building
hardware and then we saw kids are really
engaged kids kids really love this they
were like oh my god this is amazing I
can find diamond like we dress real
problems that they had in a game but
then we also took them back to the
physical space and said but in order to
address this problem here is here's some
hardware you have to build you have to
understand a little bit about what these
elements are you have to understand
about how current flow is you have to
understand about inputs and outputs and
and that that was that's actually
currently where we're at we we launched
this product you know the one that I
just showed you here it is we yeah we
demoed this with
hundreds I think at this point close to
a thousand kids and again we went
through many iterations right the story
that I was telling you start with the
black box then we slowly iterated added
different components out of different
features different designs and the final
version is here and what you do is you
know you first get the computer you you
plug in the pieces to make it work but
you only you only have a mouse first
thing you do is you build a controller
this one here I don't have a mouse when
it's at the bottom so DIY minecraft
controller then you start adding sensors
buttons buzzers lights and all these
empower you in the game to move forward
yeah so we've designed the whole
experience to not need a keyboard which
you know there are some people we've had
a lot of talks about it this has been a
big point in our discussions should we
have a keyboard which is because you
know a keyboard expands the
possibilities but it also allows you
takes it out of the game to go do other
stuff and for now we want to have just
one experience we want the user to go
through so how it works is there's ten
levels and each of the ten levels show
you how to build a certain piece a
button a switch a buzzer a light motion
detector we're adding a camera module
and then after you've played through the
ten levels and you've beaten the game
you actually have an open sandbox world
where you can use the hardware that
you've constructed previously and marry
it to software power-ups if you had a
switch controlling a bridge you can make
that switch now get you an elevator or
dig you a shaft if you had a button that
was opening hidden doors you can
actually make that button explode box in
front of you and there's no there's no
software there's no coding in this this
is just a way for kids to learn about
electronics to build their first
electronics to see that you know
technology isn't a black box it's not
something that you just get and works by
magic it's something that I actually can
build myself and I can actually empower
myself to move forward and to get solve
the problems I need solved and that's
currently where we're at yeah my
personal
is commercial product or is today so we
got lucky because the Raspberry Pi
actually has a Creative Commons license
minecraft that every standard micro
Raspberry Pi operating system comes with
and they creatively for educational
purposes so it has an API so we're able
to use it to use it for commercial
purposes and the way we modified us
through that API and one of the one of
the experimental things that we're
working on right now is okay we we want
to go beyond you know this current box
that we have into something that allows
kids to build their own tools to build
their own electronics so one of the
things we're experimenting with you know
as having potentially expansion packs
that we send out later to players and
this this would be one of them you get a
camera module and a motion detector and
through the game you would you would see
how those hook up you would kind of say
like based on this input trigger this
output or trigger the camera put it away
in there very very simple again through
the Minecraft interface and kids would
be able to make their own gadgets and
devices and the great thing of minecraft
is it's actually it's a CAD software
right so if they then wanted to move
forward and say okay I build this I
actually want a form factor around it
they could design that form factor in
Minecraft and then we get 3d printed for
them so the way we want to take this
further is steam power kids to actually
create their own mini gadgets and many
devices and and if I'm anything about
this prototypes we were running you know
we set this up overnight and the next
day we we didn't come in we had some
meetings and so we didn't come into the
office and it's actually you know some
folks came by our space where we work
and they were like they were looking at
the boxes and you know the motion sensor
triggered the camera so we took photos
of them and I don't if you guys know who
this is but this is actually even Upton
the inventor of the Raspberry Pi he
actually came by the space and then he
later sent us a photo himself and we
were holding the box but we caught him
on camera and instead of this photo
so that's sort of the I think my story
and the story of Piper and how Piper
came to be and what we're hoping to do
we're hoping to create technology and
tools to allow this generation of kids
who are you know core digital natives
but don't necessarily know or understand
the deep underlyings the deep
underpinnings of of the software and the
hardware they're using we want to give
them ways to get into that and to start
building with that and to basically
empower them and show them that it's not
it's not hard it's not magic and you can
do it yourself
what do you believe needs to know to
survive
I see it's an interesting question I
mean some would argue that not much yeah
a lot of a lot of the it depends on you
know what you're talking about
plenty of kids today use use apps and
devices and they don't need to know
anything about how they work and that's
a lot a lot of app makers a lot of
device makers especially Apple they try
to streamline and tailor their devices
and apps so the user doesn't have to
know any knowledge now you're asking me
like my opinion about what I think these
are showing I think it depends on you
know what age they are and what they
want to do later in life one three year
old granddaughter knows how to grab
passwords from her mother and log onto
our machine video answer I have an 11
year old granddaughter who writes video
games scratch through her own design and
finds bugs in the rather sloppy
implementation processes using what
language scratch scratch yes and so I
think I think you know it's not
to where what what's needed for kids to
survive in I think we need to do more
than just let kids survive I think kids
need to understand some basics and but I
think it's the those aren't basics that
we should be teaching them we shouldn't
have a curriculum that says here do this
I mean I think a lot of you in this room
I did definitely have experiences where
you wanted to do something there was a
game you were playing you wanted to get
more lives and you were like maybe I can
actually hack the code to get myself
more lives right that none those those
aha moments those moments where you're
like wow I just I just hacked something
I just did something I wasn't supposed
to do and it worked those are the
moments I think that push people to
learn more and to understand more and
then to grow as an engineer or just just
as a person who knows about what's going
on in the world I think from there
people will explore and have a
motivation I think we need to give you
what the motivation and let them have
the tools and specifying a curriculum
about what specifically they need to
know I think you know I don't think
that's that's the way I don't think that
works I'm totally amazed that there
isn't even the mention of a NAND gate
here okay I mean yes there's Turing
automatron and all that but long before
that there's basic one and zero okay
before there's even a number bigger than
that and there's combining them using
and or gates and and Brewers okay
and I'm like trying to figure out how it
is that you're gonna compete teach true
competency not something superficial
like I can be this little pattern thing
without basically covering the basics
absolutely redstone to him oh I know
redstone and I've seen the
implementations of ale use in in terms
of Minecraft but when it comes to
crafting a digital circuit I personally
would not prefer to render it in terms
of Minecraft if I want to understand
what I mean I've looked at you can't
really understand what a Minecraft ale
udot's I mean I think there's different
levels of complexity and detail that you
can start with and I mean the reason we
start started with webpages in the
beginning is because it's something that
can you can do we can type a line or two
lines of HTML and then pop it up in your
browser and see right there immediately
what you've made the point the point I'm
making is that it's it's not actually I
mean the way I think you're approaching
it is you know you need to lay down the
foundations and teach at all
step-by-step from the beginning and the
way we wanted to approach it is what is
interesting for the kids I mean right
now you can take a CS class and you can
take you can take a CS degree at
Stanford and learn all these things
right very few people do that and the
people who do that are the people who
were inspired to do that at some early
age because their dad was an engineer or
they hacked something when they were
younger and we want to give those early
experiences to more people those
experiences of hacking something up
showing them that it's okay to build
something to break something
to tweak something this isn't this isn't
a teaching device that's supposed to
teach you electronics from the very
beginning this is just a way for you to
play the game of Minecraft and to feel
that you can actually do something
yourself you can actually it's not it's
not a passive experience it's an active
experience of building that that's that
that's the idea here you know they use
these fairly large curly complicated
components like microprocessors and
memories which are not really
necessarily easily explained because
they include many components highly
specialized and they're put together in
a path which has very high resolution to
the point could even take the top off
these things you can't see these days
you load your CPU onto an FPGA and and
gates and markets are at the bottom
those kids new English so what start
just the Raspberry Pi you're not how
long do these things I ask before they
step on or static electricity
I've had a problem with static
electricity it's funny because Joel my
co-founder he has really long hair and
gather static shocks to have the day and
it's fine
with static in terms of how rugged they
are they're pretty rugged we even add
like some some pieces break off and they
still work some pins broke off other
stuff they get stopped stepped on
they're pretty they're pretty rugged I
mean we're starting to include the ones
we're shipping with cases but even even
in schools in India and Ghana they they
worked for the duration of the pilot
software doesn't crash yeah we were we
did have some problems with I mean and
there's me because we had so many pieces
right we had the screen we had keyboards
there are a lot of moving parts while
the Raspberry Pi was was fine
other other components either died or
the battery he got damaged and transit
so the better like other other hardware
pieces sometimes failed on us the
specific implementation that we had
running in the browser that was also
hard to do because the PI doesn't have
any very strong browsers right now the
chromium is it's kind of okay there's in
Dori so we had some problems with
running our software but we quickly I
mean there was there was even bigger
problems and like that the screen didn't
turn on there's like like a small wire
got ripped yeah you talked about we did
this we did that what we're trying to do
the kids saw something how many kids
what is the what what is the entity
that's doing this work who how many
people are involved how is it what's the
business model or the funding or I would
way to other than your desire to do good
things from the world so we started with
several people myself colleague at
Oxford tree who's as an undergraduate at
Harvard she she does a lot of education
stuff so you come over with the
curriculum we initially we actually just
sent these computers into the India
these we sent him we send them with a
group that was already going to
volunteer so we trained some volunteers
and they actually wanted implemented
this later what we're doing in the
States we actually went ourselves like I
was there in person with a few other
teammates and we'd give these two kids
we go into classrooms or after school
programs or workshops we give these two
kids for about an hour long and we'd
kind of document we have questions you
know as this engaging as this
interesting so and currently our team is
myself Joel was a co-founder CTO shree's
she's an advisor and also co-founder and
she just advises on the educational
stuff we have a game designer engineer
and another guy
China doing sourcing and supply chain
stuff but there's three core and I guess
I call myself an engineer now after
building a lot of the product myself we
have three core engineers who building
product right now and what was the other
thing yes I'm not sure if you are a
bunch of friends that enjoy doing stuff
or through the company all this are you
being championed by somebody and you
have a patron or some yeah so we
actually came out to San Francisco
because Zenga org nonprofit arm of Zynga
they have an educational games incubator
so we applied and they asked us to come
out here so we're working out of their
space and they invested a small amount
invested fifty thousand to cover our
expenses and then we just recently ran a
Kickstarter campaign where we pre-sold
close to fourteen hundred units and that
was about two hundred eighty thousand
dollars that we received from that that
we're now using as you know a part of
our runway to fulfill the orders and
then also I mean on the side that's how
we got touch with Andy is what we're
doing some fundraising to bring it and
the reason we're doing fundraising is
we're bringing on another engineer on
board want to expand the feature set
that we have for the December ship we
also want to have some inventory on hand
to ship more units because because we're
getting orders monthly right now how do
you get hooked up with all the kids
you're testing on what are the
organizations you're working through
yeah that was just through the so the
incubator they have just connections and
teachers and schools I was just actually
personally a lot of cold calling schools
I would call them and say hey we have
this tool kit we want to try it out with
your students in a lot of a lot of
teachers they they actually don't have
anything disengaging kids get really
engaged with this so after that they
tell other teachers and they want to
bring us into other schools in the
district and kind of what the way we do
it with kids is again you know we bring
them something we ask them questions
about it we do we have them test the
storyline the game design elements we
also kind of we actually lead them
through the design process as well kind
of some of the pieces that I told you
about today we tell that to the kids and
we kind of tell them you know you're
part of this process and
what you tell us today would actually
influence how the game was forward but
but we worked with beside schools the
tech museum San Jose after school and
after-school programs and workshops and
in the city and the Bay Area Khan
Academy yeah we're actually talking
about doing something this summer at the
lab school there
no we haven't haven't done anything the
Explorer yeah I think there was some we
tried actually there was people have
gotten to about where you have and then
hit a ceiling all the way back to
Seymour Papert and logo and the little
turtles of those guys and there's tons
of little electronics kiss you can find
at the back of radio Radio Shack's being
liquidated and you know they get about
to the level where you can couple
objects like cakes together and make
lights go on and off I don't think kind
of gets stuck as the next step up
requires a much bigger jump in
abstraction so far basically it looks
like you you funded and my current line
graph to place an obstacle in front of
kids who want to play Minecraft they
have to get through to play Minecraft
but I'm going to take a look at FIRST
Robotics which is now at the level of
having a very sophisticated control or
programming and LabVIEW I mean there's a
manual list this thing for the thing now
and I'm amazed at the what what's
available there is there a useful place
about halfway in between where first is
now and where you are now
for kids to move up into yeah so several
things right here I think we're talking
might electronics kids I think the the
paradigm of all that is snap circuits
and like it's a very early like you buy
it for your kid you can do some very
basic things hook up a light and then
engagement after that drops you do it
with your kid for an hour and then it's
done so and then and you're saying like
yeah you guys have the minecraft
engagement piece well what's next so
kind of just just to be clear what piper
actually offers in its current state is
a way to get it's not just like you know
here's a barrier to get to Minecraft
it's more like here's actually a way
to get a 10x experience in Minecraft
instead of like digging for hours to get
diamonds find them very easily or here's
an adventure where like you're gonna go
do this this and this and you're
actually gonna experience power-ups that
you usually don't get in the gameplay of
your regular pocket or PC Edition so
it's not it's not actually just here's a
different way to play my cards actually
here's a better way to play Minecraft
I'm working right now on an integration
with Pocket Edition and there's about 10
million active players on Pocket Edition
so what would that wow that would work
is you'd be playing some kind of map
Pocket Edition you would integrate it to
your pie addition you would build out
very quickly and powerfully whatever you
want it to build out then you go back to
the Pocket Edition continue playing and
network that with your friends etc but
to your point about you know how do you
move up I think several ways because
we're using the Raspberry Pi right now
that has a lot of that offers us you
know pretty wide range of possibilities
where we can take this and you know one
of the things I mean you even this
motion-sensing motion-activated camera
that's one of things that were
experimenting with kind of taking it
beyond just very basic circuit building
but how do you make devices I didn't
make gadgets and lots of people are
building on the PI lots of people are
creating modules you can plug in and
we're hoping to leverage that the other
thing is we're using off-the-shelf
components and parts so if people
themselves want to create things for the
PI or for Piper and share it it's very
easy to integrate but moving forward I
think we're we want to go is into a
space where kids are using mod modular
modules like like the camera like them
like motion sensors maybe even like a
spark core that integrates with with
Wi-Fi right and when when something
happens and sends you a text message and
basically letting kids and anyone for
that matter
moving forward create very easily create
hardware connected hardware create again
create connected gadgets because right
now you have all these great tools you
have Arduino you have Raspberry Pi but
there's barriers to getting into that
hobbyists and people who have the time
to spend to learn those platforms
they can get really good and they can
make stuff right we were just at Maker
Faire there's lots of great things at
Maker Faire but there's no easy way in
especially into hardware and that's
that's doesn't that's the place where
we're moving into creating a platform
let anyone create with hardware there
easily yeah so what's the cost of this
were you making it and what are you
doing so this is version one the wooden
box I don't know if we have one here
will show you after but that currently
is priced at $1.99 and yeah it's it's
quite expensive for several reasons
we're using there's no because we're
using just standard components and we
don't make anything custom we just
whatever the price we're given we have
to take the other thing is we wanted to
on the business end we want to prove out
what price point is okay and it's easier
to reduce the price later then to
increase it so we started with something
high and we're gonna reduce it but but
even like more fundamentally I think
we're gonna shift into more of a version
two which we think would be just a chip
as you're dreaming at the high end there
are people who are wishing the $35 I'm
not sure so that's actually what I was
about to say which is we see a version
of this that where it's more like 30 to
40 dollars where you just get a chip and
a box of electronics that's compatible
with this chip and you interface this
with your phone with a computer and all
of us already have screens right there's
screens you don't need us to give you a
screen you don't need us to give you a
lot of these a lot of these pieces you
already have them so we give you a chip
and that chip interfaces with your phone
with your computer whether we're using
my like we probably will be using
minecraft going forward using the
Minecraft that exists and your devices
your interface it with a chip you're
building the hardware on this chip that
you bought for 30 40 dollars and you're
getting the same
the same gameplay from that so you're
saying completely virtualize everything
well you can virtualize a programmable
logic device in software and you can
teach kids how to program it without
even giving them one right I mean part
of the whole vision here is to give kids
hands-on thanks to build it's a chip
great like like a nine dollar computer
or Raspberry Pi that you're still you're
still building in the same way than
you're building here and there's just
instead of us providing you this screen
you provide your own screen yeah so you
know so we have a team member in China
who's who's sourced parts before and his
source actually had a company doing
solar panels so he's on our team he's in
charge of the supply chain and so we're
so I mean we've kind of we have all that
on a timeline we're shipping for
Christmas because we're using standard
off-the-shelf parts there's minimal time
delays in terms of if we need to scale
up or down and you asked about costs and
we can discuss cost kind of offline
yeah yeah are we gonna stop right now
it's just it's just online and we had
the Kickstarter and from there people
have just been ordering pre-ordering
online since then just just from that
initial publicity from that we're
interested in going into schools I think
a homeschool market especially is very
underserved in terms of stem curriculum
we are speaking with several homeschool
distributors go into home schools for
schools it's it's much harder and that
that's that's one route but that's
probably a long term
directory and long-term plan and I mean
also going on to store shelves
that's another option and we we're
speaking with with Mattel right now so
the second product is kind of what what
I'm telling there's there's two there's
two pieces here second product family
right is something that's around $50 and
that interfaces with an existing
minecraft interface whether it's your
computer your Xbox your iPhone and
allows you to have the same experiences
interactions you have currently with
Piper but to do it at lower cost and to
do it with an existing device a platform
that you have so you're still building
hardware and electronics and if you want
to actually remove the Minecraft helmet
and just build yourself on this platform
right and the platform would would be
sort of like a Raspberry Pi without a
chip pens and put output power etc
there's very basic things to get you get
you started and to get you to have the
interactions in the virtual world that
you want that that's what we're aiming
towards because then from there we can
go into what I'm talking about creating
your own Hardware creating your own
connected devices right if you we know
what chip you're using we know what the
hardware is you told us you built this
you can then 3d print a case around it
and there you have your emotion camera
your prerogative programmable ball that
lights up whenever you press the button
whatever it is that's that's the
direction we're going to yeah
we're going to mention that you cold
called everything cold call me all that
other stuff you ended up on local TV how
did you do that yeah so one of the how
do we do that
III think so one of the teachers of one
of the schools she her sister was was a
reporter so she called her sister and
said hey do you know anyone there and
her sister said let me let me just check
and ask and I think she basically and
and I had to I rose I mean so I wrote a
press release and I sent out to all the
TV stations locally but nobody responded
and I think I think her just are
actually reaching out that hit that
helped can't get her off that radar in
one of your little video segments you
were showing people working on a
terminal board but putting on little
colored blocks that seemed to be
transducers or something I wasn't
familiar with what those were it's like
a little super module of some sort that
was plugging in what were those things
you know what I'm talking about you have
the flat white terminal strip and then
there are like three colored blocks on
top just simply push buttons you really
don't like those things themselves had
terminals to them or a wire
oh I see what you're saying I think
you're talking about was it was it this
yes on that image towards the right just
below the edge of the box there's a
point sheet with some actually mini
bread boards so you can yeah you can you
can wire up there just miniaturize
breadboard and we were experimenting
with those I mean that's probably how
we're going to ship in some form like
that where it's very easy to color code
what piece you have to put on which
breadboard and it makes it more
manageable as opposed to having one huge
long
it's not a real course yeah it would be
using to make up little plug-in modules
that have exactly the semantics of
redstone components people a bigger
breadboard so they could actually have
things that did exactly what redstone
does and the indian my crowd yeah yeah I
think it's not so time delays and all
yeah yeah I think for product for a V to
that that would be something we'd
implement yeah john was asking what
about the orders of magnitude of
difference between what you build in
here well I guess there's I mean first
robotics I think that I mean in terms of
a real calibration there's a whole army
of teachers who were working on
perfecting the first robotics ever
kilograms and they do have their head
wrapped around what it takes to move a
motor and control it so as far as
affecting the real world whether it's
the Lego Mindstorm thing happening
internally in I guess is MIT you are at
Lego R&D or whether it's the first
robotic thing which I think John really
brings into focus here as a baseline as
to the kind of thing that can expected
in a curriculum that involves real true
empowerment and so the question is how
to get from ones first dabbling to this
level which is now expected for high
school students yeah I mean I think it's
important to also point out that I mean
I think FIRST Robotics kids costs on the
order of thousands of dollars and I mean
we definitely I mean I think you're
asking you know how do we move forward I
think we want to include pieces that
allow you to move robots to hover drones
etc controlling a single loader is not a
thousand dollar proposition it's more
like it
sure sure it's with the the hardware we
include you know if you're asking are we
gonna have expansion packs and we'll
have expansion packs that will have
things like that if you're asking about
the curriculum element of it we noticed
that it's very hard and again mr.
robotics are only in very few schools
because of costs because some schools
don't have the classes to teach it they
don't have the bandwidth that aren't the
experts it's intimidating for teachers a
lot of there's a lot of sort of almost
so what is the story and what's the
target eighty six-year-old
seven-year-old seven to 15 so defintely
what 15 even what is this it seems to me
that they're really sort of six and
seven and ideal the sweet spot is middle
school um so I think 15 is like on the
tail end of that yeah I mean that's
furniture what we've seen I mean we've
seen high school kids play with this and
very interesting interactive experience
um high school kids who play Minecraft
as well because you want to meet and
start new things out of them if that
means sort of medium scale or a small
scale building blocks are Muslims
maybe the only really big thing with
that process so hard it's a hard it's a
hard problem because
the tendency is that a lot of the other
kids he needs only complicated
confluence and that pushes up the cost
to meet the little models then until you
get something where to get into the game
and all of us $500 because there are 20
different modules all of which part for
me oh yeah and modules are sort of
limited as to what you do they're not
555 timers that's correct which is which
I saw it maker for the done a 555 timer
using some sort of discrete components
of a four by six form factor that's 4 by
6 inches and you're supposed to make
things with it I was confused building
block upon which you can build anything
yeah and I actually spent some money on
the snap-together things and it was
basically the response was and this was
a 14-year old well he would follow the
recipe for a while then he just said
well what happens if I just random
little things together and they'd hooked
together magnetically and if the defense
system on that particular part worked it
wouldn't destroy itself otherwise it
would because it's having useful things
and have a dent having a dense useful
space is hard and digital components are
not designed for today I have a very
sparse useful space most digital things
you can arrange for 300 bucks and mom
doesn't buy another one after that
because she says you just burned it up
and then you go back to it well ok I
have to break things for the hammer last
question you prayed in an area where
use different componentry but you can do
very interesting things in these days
why did you move to that products which
is really highly simplified or not not
as interesting as biological entities
why not build the big row and the dark
funny exactly you know what
smart slime oh yeah anything about
learning you have to attain and I'm
experience I was attained before you
actually make something in biology is
really really high you can he's talking
about programming organisms I think that
was the question the point is you can
work with life-forms never that matter
of genetic toolkit their lives and
modify them that's not that far away
demonstrates
oh there wasn't automated there was an
automated evolution stand and make the
premise this time yeah it was only
selecting for survival and the things
they were trying to make that we
shouldn't been selecting for mortality
instead which is harder what I found was
making anything interesting was like I
said how to I mean you have to get in a
lab you have to have a lot of training
on certain things if you want to make
really interesting things it takes a lot
of lead-up in terms of learning in terms
of experience in terms of getting access
to the tools you need and all these
tools are very highly specialized and I
have electronics you can give buy these
things off the shelf and you can make
something in your dorm room I feel like
it's a little more democratic in that
sense and that that's why I liked it
that's why I wanted to stick with that
you